yeah a lot of excitement brady a lot of
excitement because particle physics is
still in the game it hasn't died it's
amazing isn't it
it's it's a bit like waiting for buses i
was thinking about this the other day
you know you're waiting for a bus
and then all of a sudden three come
along at once yeah we were all worried
there was there was no new particle
physics to be found there was no new
particles we'd found everything that was
going to be found
we're waiting for a new particle and
then all of a sudden the bbc announces
at least two there are sort of
tantalising hints of some really
exciting new physics um from two
experiments recent sort of announcements
from two experiments one of them's at
cern
it's um the lhcb experiment and you
might recall we've been to the lhc and
we saw the atlas detector and we saw the
cms detector they're called general
purpose detectors these huge fantastic
pieces of kit which discovered the higgs
there are two more key detectors on the
lhc ring one is called alice and but
there's another one
lhcb so the real excitement the real
excitement is coming from
the experiment coming from fermilab
where they've been looking at the
magnetic moment of the of the muon
lhcb is is a high precision detector
that's looking for very fine events that
might not occur very often but by
searching in particular for
particular types of decay then they've
got a way of testing the standard model
of particle physics very accurately and
it's through there that this
potential new discovery has emerged what
they did was they if you remember at the
lhc they fire protons around in
opposite directions and then they
collide them and they collide them here
in in the lhcb detector
they're looking for the decay of a
particular type of meson
a meson is a combination of two quarks a
quark and an antiquark
and they're looking for a meson called a
b meson which has got a b quark in it
that we've got these three generations
of of quarks and the b meson
also called the bottom of beauty is the
b quark is often associated with the top
quark
you and i are made up of the up and down
quarks in fact
everywhere around us here all that we're
re everything around here is made up of
up and down quarks
so these b quarks are very rare and they
decay rapidly they form in these mesons
and they decay such that when they decay
they decay to another quark which is
called an s quark this is what the
particular route they're looking for a
strange quark
and
as they do so they decay producing two
leptons what are the electrons are what
you and i are made of electron is an
example of an electron of a lepton but
there's another key lepton called the
muon
and the muon is is going to be the star
of the show in particular the number of
times the b quark decays either into
electrons and a positron or muons and
it's anti-particle
and the the key thing that it's trying
to measure here is
the relative
distribution of these like how many
times does this process the decay of
this b meson go into the electrons
compared to how many times does it go
into the muons and there's a very
important principle
from the standard model called lepton
universality and just this idea of
universality suggests that there's a
common theme between the various leptons
and in fact the belief is that
you should produce electrons just as
often as you produce the muons
so that if you can detect enough of
these decays then you'll find half of
them the time they're electrons and half
of the time they're muons
well about uh
a decade or so ago there were
experiments which suggested this wasn't
quite working out that actually they
were producing muons at a a slower rate
than they were producing the electrons
whereas you would have expected them to
be at the same rate and so what they
have done
this quite remarkable
team of working at the lhcb is they've
been assembling data from 2012 in fact i
think maybe even earlier but certainly
2012 onwards
looking at all the decays of these b
mesons into what are called k masons but
basically it's the bottom quark
decay or the beauty quark decaying to
the strange
and looking at the output in terms of
number of electrons and number of muons
you would expect in sound processes that
you would decay just as equally in terms
into electrons as you would into muons
there's no there's no preference there
because the couplings are the same
everything's just working at the same
strength
but that's not what seems to be
happening there seems to be a preference
for for electrons the ratio of the
number of times you decay to the muon
divided by the number of times you decay
to the electron isn't one but it's about
0.8 so it's decaying to the muon far
less often than it's decaying to the
electron
and an interpretation of that
is that maybe there's another particle
playing a role in this that we haven't
detected that's played no major role in
anything else we've seen
but it's actually stopping the muon
somehow from being from
from it decaying to the muon it's
allowing the electron route to go
through but somehow it's stopping the
muon
and so
it's there's been a lot of work on this
type of thing for many years
and there's a number of particles out
there which have been suggested as
possible ways of explaining this and
probably the most
common one that people have thought of
is called a leptoquark
leptons and quarks we usually think of
as totally separate particles but a
lepto kind of is a new particle which
brings them together and and it has
properties of both leptons and quarks so
it can feel the strong force as well as
just feeling the the the weak force that
the electromagnetism force that that the
quarks the electrons feel
and so i think there's going to be a lot
of interest in the possibility that this
process is now taking place so there's
this new particle
existing for a very short period of time
that then decays into quarks and leptons
and it's in such a way that it's
preventing
the b the beauty quark from decaying
into the muon as often as it decays into
the electron why does it have to be a
particle why can't it just be that
nature
favors the electron route or something
like that it's a very good question and
in fact
the standard model seems to suggest that
it should go evenly in both directions
so if it's favoring one clearly favoring
one over the other
we're assuming that the experiment is is
correct and is picking up all the new
ones that are being created
then
it's hard to do it within the standard
model itself so now so then what do you
do and it's just that the easiest thing
to try and come up with is another
particle one thing i should mention
is
perhaps it gets a little bit technical
but it's a boson we have our fermions
the stuff that you and i are made of the
matter in the universe is made up of
fermions things with spin half
but these are effectively bosons which
are force carriers
so
the photon has a spin one the graviton
has a spin too and this is this has got
a an integer spin it's a boson and so it
actually also acts as a force
so it could be that this is in the news
you might have heard you know they talk
about a fifth force
and this is acting as that fifth force
but it's hard to reconcile it simply
within the standard model and so you
have to come up with something and if
you've got your favorite candidate that
you can think of that might be some
fluid or then bring it to the table in
fact there are many candidates i
mentioned the leptor quarks some people
think of a particle called a z-prime
particle this is just the z-particle but
very massive said particle and then
there's another called vector
vector quarks which are sort of there's
a whole series of them
so the second boss that came brown
is also quite remarkable i mean this is
the g minus two muon experiment so what
the muon is is like the the electrons
heavier cousin it's essentially very
like the electron in every sense and but
it's heavier it's about 200 times
heavier than the than the electron and
just like the electron it has what's
called a magnetic moment this basically
just is is is it's a little bit of sort
of intrinsic magnetism before we
describe it let's just let me just give
you a little bit of background of this
experiment which is a ring
basically which is 50 feet across 15
meters
it was initially performed at the
brookhaven national laboratory on long
island
and then once they'd finished and done
its experiment they decided the people
involved in it decided they would like
to upgrade it and also take it to
somewhere where there's a better source
of new ones but to get it from long
island to fermilab which is in batavia
illinois
rather than going over cross land it
went out down the north atlantic
up through down to sort of new orleans
up through the mississippi river into
the illinois river and then got put on
around chicago area got put on a huge
huge lorry and got taken up the highway
to fermilab what this experiment does is
again it looks at the muon
if you didn't have sort of you know all
the corrections coming from quantum
field theory things like that then the
magnetic moment of the of the mu on like
the electron it would be two it would
just be the the number two that's
related to the fact that it that it uh
it has spin a half but the answer is not
exactly two okay it's slightly bigger
than two the magnetic moment of the of
the of the moon is slightly bigger than
two and the reason is the reason it's
slightly bigger is it comes from sort of
quantum corrections to that number so
what happens is is the muon it can sort
of shapeshift
and the mu one is a particle that's got
a charge and so it's got a dipole which
means it acts like a little dipole
magnet a bar magnet and if you if you
move that
muon in a magnet in a circle in a
magnetic field it will begin to
wobble a bit like a spinning top you
know if you push a spinning top down and
let it go around it just it doesn't keep
at the same height it sort of wobbles as
it goes around
and you can measure the frequency of
this wobble
now the frequency of this wobble tells
you about the strength of the magnet
that the dipole is it's called the
magnetic moment of the dipole
so this is what's being measured okay
and
the the strength of this dipole it can
give off a a photon and then reabsorb it
and this will create a correction to to
the you know the predicted value for the
for the magnetic moment that photon
itself can sort of shapeshift into an
electron positron pair that can then be
created and annihilate become another
photon which gets reabsorbed there are
all these sort of quantum corrections
this cloud of quantum corrections that
can affect the value for the uh for the
magnetic moments but then people
sort of
naturally said well it's not just
electrons and quantum electrodynamics
that could be important maybe
w and z bosons might be important maybe
they're popping in and out of existence
as well and so they started doing
calculations based on the what's called
the vacuum fluctuations of these
particles
and they modified this number it still
was
two 2.00223 but you had more digits
added on
and everything was fine until you reach
the seventh digit the seventh decimal
place because at that point
you have to start including the effects
of quantum chromodynamics the quarks
that can exist
and they they're formed by
the electron or the muon it could be any
of these electrons and and the muon
being much heavier is one that is worth
probing because it can create these
extra particles around it in the vacuum
fluctuations
the muon
can lead to a photon will emerge
a virtual photon then decay and then
from it comes a quark antiquark pair
which then reconnects
to a photon and then it gets reabsorbed
by the mu and that's the process but
this quark antiquark pair you have to be
able to account for and that's where the
problem is what we found in 2001 was
that the theoretical expectation for the
for the magnetic moment was different to
the to the observed prediction they
disagreed at the eighth decimal place
okay so the eighth decimal place when
you really start to probe these rare
processes the numbers differed and so
people at the time got very excited
about this but of course it wasn't
statistically significant then i think
it was around a sort of three sigma
results okay and then
you know
not quite enough to classes as a genuine
discovery in particle physics but enough
to get people excited so the theory now
is to try and calculate that
and there are two approaches to these
calculations for the quarks they they're
called the virtual hadron processes
and
they differ
now one of them differs in a way which
is consistent with the observation of
this experiment which i'll now describe
and the other differs in a way which
leaves it inconsistent so their value
for g is inc is different
to the experimental value by 4.2 sigma
and if you recall five sigma difference
between a theory and an experimental
value would be a discovery
4.2 is pretty good it's getting close
isn't it the experiment is this 50 feet
or 15 meters
for our european colleagues ring so
fermilab they can produce high-energy
muons they fire them into the ring and
they go around in a big magnetic field
and if you recall i said that because
they've got a magnetic dipole they begin
to wobble a muon's heavier 200 times
heavier than a than an electron
otherwise pretty much identical
it doesn't want to stay there it lives
for about a millionth of a second by
which time it's circled around about a
few hundred times but it then decays
to an electron it produces an electron
and the electron gets detected in the
detectors surrounding the ring
and the muons are carrying on going
around and decaying and
by the by looking at the energy of the
electron that comes out and the
direction that it comes into the
detector you know about the wobble
and the wobble if you recall the wobble
of its sort of parent muon yes exactly
and that wobble tells me directly about
the muon magnetic moment this g that
we're trying to get it's very hard to
calculate these these sort of hydronic
contributions to the magnetic moment of
the muon it's very difficult to
calculate
but people got better at doing the
calculations they started to zoom in on
an agreed value for for the sort of
standard prediction
and then of course we needed a better
experiment which could really pin down
what the observational result was and
they've done this now for they've been
doing this experiment for the past
i don't know five
five six years
and they've begun to they've now started
releasing their data they've released
the first six percent of their data the
key thing they're trying to do of course
is control the errors
reduce the systematics make sure they
understand and i
sadly i can't do that justice but that's
a remarkable achievement that they've
done so the theory seems to have
tightened up a bit but also the
experiment is as has now tightened up as
well and now we've got over a four sigma
result which again is still not quite
enough for it to clusters of particle
physics discovery
but it's really starting to get
interesting now and it does seem that
it's sensitive to new physics it was all
done blind
so that when they released the data all
of the teams saw it for the first time
there was a key thing a key frequency
clock which was
they didn't know about and that they
were given that information that then
allowed them to plug it into a
key formula to get what g is
and they found the number g that they
got was the same
as the number that they they'd got at
the brooklyn national laboratory
and if you remember what i've just said
that is 4.2 sigma away from the
theoretical prediction that came from
this international group of of uh
physicists who were working on the
theory behind it
and so there was this remarkable result
that's emerged that suggests if it holds
that the theory is based on standard
model physics
the experiment is the experiment you
just do the measurement and it's once
again suggesting that there's something
else happening that the muons
are being
tilted a bit more because the actually
the theory result is slow is smaller the
value of g from theory is smaller than
the value of g from the experiment
and so it means the magnetic effect is
larger in the experiment so whatever is
causing this change if it is new physics
is causing the muon to have a slightly
larger internal magnetic field than it
otherwise would and leptor quarks and
other possible candidates are out there
let me see if i've understood this
correctly
it sounds to me like
in in nature in physics
there are particles popping into and out
of existence spontaneously all the time
like a sort of a soup yes and one way to
detect that soup to measure what's in it
what vegetables and carrots and sprouts
and things are in it is to look at how
that soup affects muons
and so they've been doing really really
good experiments with muons to see how
they're being affected as they travel
through this soup to get a better and
better idea of what's in the soup
perfect and now that they're getting
these measurements better and better
there's a new vegetable that they've
never seen before absolutely there's
this quantum soup that surrounds all the
particles now you can imagine taking the
particle out of the soup right and
that's what we do with our first
approximation in our calculations we
take the particle out of the suit we do
the calculation we make a prediction
okay but then we start putting the
particle in the soup right and we see
that the soup starts to affect our
results and absolutely you're right if
there's some sort of i don't know alpha
spaghetti spaghetti floating around in
there or something it's going to affect
your results and muons indeed because
they're heavier they're more sensitive
to that unexpected unknown physics
that's that's that could be out there
then say the electron would have been
this is a really interesting
time
first of all it's worth pointing out at
the beginning i mentioned this high
precision experiments these deviations
between the experiment and the
theoretical predictions are in the
eighth decimal place of the calculation
and also
there is another group i said of these
two theory groups approaching this
problem the theory group that the
experimental group have aligned with in
in the sense of comparing their results
directly with have had to incorporate
experimental data into their analysis
not not the experiment
of the g minus two but other
experimental data to deal with this
hadron question the vacuum polarization
of the hadrons
the and they're the ones that have come
out with the very low number 4.2 sigma
away we maybe shouldn't get ahead of
ourselves it might not be a new particle
right so what it could be is it could be
that the theory prediction is still not
right
and it's a really unusual state of
affairs now we actually have there's
been a rival paper which is claims to
have done the the theory calculation in
a different way and gets a result that's
more in line with just with standard
model physics nothing fancy but which is
more in line with the observed volume
there is another group of people a
smaller group but that have just simply
used qcd
on a supercomputer they've just looked
at lattice q
euclidean lattice qcd it's called worked
on a supercomputer no experimental input
using the standard model and they have
come out with the result which is
actually compatible with the experiment
okay
and so we are in this amazing situation
where
we have the two theory approaches this
this shows you how we
that science is not a single track to
get to somewhere these two theory
approaches both trying to solve a
problem are coming in with numbers which
are inconsistent with each other one of
them is consistent with the experiment
which was consistent with the original
experiment so it suggests the experiment
is okay right if these two are
consistent 20 years apart sort of
accepted result the one that we're
saying is different to the to the
observation
what they do is they they take a sort of
data-driven approach
they're worried about the effect of
these hadrons in the quantum soup right
so
those are very difficult to calculate
hadrons they're strongly coupled they're
all tied in with gluons in this sort of
gluey mesh it's difficult quarks are a
pain to deal with right
this is difficult so rather than
actually try to calculate that because
it's too hard they take input from other
experiments or this so it's a
data-driven approach say well given what
that experiment's showing this probably
suggests that this value of this thing
is about this therefore we'll calculate
the rest then they get an answer for the
magnetic moment of the muon
that doesn't agree with experiments
but the other guys this bmw
collaboration they're called right
nothing to do with the cars named after
budapest marseille and uh vuter pal i
think the name of your city is so this
this bmw correlation what they've done
is they've shoved everything into a
computer a really fancy spanking super
computer that literally puts all those
quarks on and hadrons on a giant lattice
and does the brute force calculation
right
really really sophisticated something
that you could never have done decades
ago really powerful calculation and
they've done and so they've done this
calculation they're getting something
more in line why don't we just think
that the first group are the one that
got it right
that seems like the more obvious
solution yes i mean it and and and quite
a few
people think this will probably may turn
out to be correct which would be in some
ways sad
if you're really looking for new physics
which we know has to be there somewhere
we still don't know why they
we're certain about matter and not
antimatter we don't know what the dark
matter is we need some new physics it's
entirely possible that there's some
systematics that aren't quite right in
the in the lattice calculation in the
bmw calculation but maybe not it's a
really really impressive calculation
that those guys have done or maybe the
data-driven calculation isn't right but
even if the data-driven calculation
isn't right there's something going on
here because they're using data
so it's like is there something we're
not understanding about
that part of the data and how we feed it
into this calculation it still suggests
smells that there's something we're not
understanding about fundamental physics
here so either way whether the whoever's
right about the the prediction here
there's something going on that we don't
understand it might not be the magnetic
moment experiment that that's that's
we're missing it might be something else
i think the fact that we're seeing
something at the lhcb
this
muon this decay of the beauty quark
to muons
far less than than it goes to electrons
and then this g minus two also involving
the muons
is suggesting there's something going on
the muons the heavier leptons
are being affected by this by something
and so i'd i'd like to
waver on the side of saying there's
something there i think it's a new
physics i i really do
and
so
there is i mean look there are reasons
for other reasons to expect new physics
to be just around the corner you know we
talk about why is the higgs particle so
light this is a mystery that we don't
understand why is hex particles so light
new physics can explain it you know
there's things like what is dark matter
you know we know dark matter's out there
we need a particle to explain it where
is it
okay we there's there's another sort of
quirk which is that the the um
we like to think that all the different
coupling strengths of particle physics
will come together and unify at some
high energies and you need new physics
to make that happen so this this
beautiful elegance so there's lots of
reasons to expect that new physics is
just around the corner it's why we built
the lhc for example right so
the fact that they had now and this is
why everyone was freaking out because it
was like it didn't seem like there was
any no experiment was showing anything
up except for this
this is finally
pushing us in that direction that maybe
there is something there you just have
to look in the right place and that's
really exciting the day after the day
after this announcement of g minus 2
30 papers appeared on the archive
another 13 today that paper the prl that
has appeared
already has 36 citations after two days
it's just kind of through the roof now
of course there'll be
a thousand papers i'm exaggerating but
there'll be a lot of papers come out in
the next few days people ambulance
chasing explaining what explains this
this this new new phenomena i mean we
were i was chatting to some
collaborators yesterday right and we
weren't thinking about the the muon
experiment you know the neon experiments
at all we were just thinking about
trying to explain dark energy and string
theory and then we had this particle in
it that
i was a bit worried about how light this
particle was and what what it might
affect and we did some digging while we
were on teams obviously everyone's on
teams aren't they
and we actually came across a constraint
based on neuromagnetic moments and i was
like well this could be a you know sort
of joking right but you never know these
two announcements have obviously made a
real celebrity of the muon
which which is a particle that doesn't
get a lot of love i don't know much
about muons i like the new one why are
you even harsh on the view of i think
it's great you make it sound like
they're really unstable do they are
there muons in this room on a permanent
basis or are they kind of uh sort of a
transient visitor they'll be if they're
there they'll just be trans yeah they're
certainly not here sort of on a
permanent basis and and they
they were first detected by cosmic rays
you know the cosmic rays is this we need
to do something on cosmic rays by the
way but the cosmic rays
the highest energy particles we've got
hit the atmosphere and and
produce all fundamental particles that
that
that are
consistent with the e equals m c squared
and the muon is one of them it decay it
decays in about a millionth of a second
so if they're popping up here they're
decaying very rapidly do you get jealous
that the experimentalists seem to get
all the headlines and the big moments
and the big stories
i'll behave i mean like a lot the
superstars of physics are all theorists
right of course they are
that's that's without question so so now
i mean come on einstein new and all
these superstars they're all theories
certainly experimentalists are just the
lumpers
don't say that don't forget
allows you then to read off where the
particles have come from the particles
aren't affected they then move out to a
second set of detectors
called the calorimeters and the
calorimeters actually stop the particles